es ist ein absoluter meilenstein google
hat den quanten prozessor brüssel
vorgestellt er ist der leistungsfähigste
quantencomputer der welt und wäre der
schnellste computer der welt überhaupt
wenn ja wenn da nicht noch ein kleiner
haken wäre alles über den meilenstein in
der computerentwicklung jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
es ist der nächste große schritt zu auf
einen spektakulären moment die
technologische singularität wird diese
vorhergesagte technologische
singularität ein wird die technik den
menschen überholen und sich selbst
ständig neu erfinden dann ist die
entwicklung der menschheit nicht mehr
vorhersagbar und es könnten riesige
technologische fortschritte in kürzester
zeit erreicht werden oder die künstliche
intelligenz ki übernimmt die macht ja
den quantencomputer haben einen
entscheidenden vorteil sie sind
dramatisch viel weniger begrenzt als die
herkömmlichen computer die aus schaltern
und speichern bestehen ihre technische
entwicklung ist deutlich langsamer und
extrem durch die physik begrenzt wärme
geschwindigkeit der elektronen
kapazitäten usw beim quantencomputer ist
das vollkommen anders hier gibt es tipps
die auch zwischen zustände annehmen
können das erlaubt den quantencomputern
weitaus komplexere berechnung in weitaus
kürzerer zeit so können riesige
datenmengen in wahnsinnig kurzer zeit
analysiert werden komplexe abläufe wie
zum beispiel das klima oder das wetter
können viel besser durchgerechnet werden
und und und und jetzt hat john martinis
von der university of california in
santa barbara den neuen google quanten
prozessor vorgestellt der alles bisher
dagewesene in den schatten stellt 72
kubitz auf einem schiff das ist der
absolute wahnsinn 20 cubes galten bisher
als grenze an 50 cubes ist man jetzt
dran aber 72 das ist absolut google will
damit nichts weniger als die welt
verändern auf einem solchen prozessor
könnte eine künstliche intelligenz
laufen die alles bisher dagewesene in
den schatten stellt dann das ist die
oberste priorität bei google künstliche
intelligenz ki zuerst oder auf englisch
artificial intelligence
first bei google hat man sich wie bei
ibm für elektronische schaltkreise
entschieden in den supraleitenden
mikrochips integriert sind und mit dem
72 jubels ist man jetzt der konkurrenz
meilenweit voraus noch ist ein rechner
mit diesem chip nicht gebaut worden aber
das könnte wohl relativ schnell
geschehen und dann wäre er
wahrscheinlich der schnellste rechner
der welt aber quantencomputer haben
einen großen haken sie sind
fehleranfällig war eine wettkampf der
quantencomputer im letzten jahr waren
die fehler immens ein ibm rechner trat
gegen einen quantencomputer der
university of maryland an der ibm
rechner war teilweise bis zu tausenden
halt schneller als sein konkurrent
dieser hatte jedoch eine höhere
zuverlässigkeit er kam auf einen wert
von 77 bis 90 während der ibm rechner
nur auf 35 74 prozent kam
das muss man sich mal vorstellen im
matheunterricht herr lehrer ich war zu
35 prozent sicher ja das ist schon ein
riesiger nachteil allerdings wollen die
google vorstand die fehlerquote deutlich
nach unten drücken
sie soll unter 0 5 prozent liegen mit
einem quantencomputer mit neuen kibiz
soll dieser wert schon erreicht worden
seien ja wenn er als erstes neues zu
diesem wahnsinnigen thema
quantencomputern dass in zukunft noch
eine menge zu erwarten und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer bei diesen link dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
von pixum mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hierbei
klicks und passiert der direkte draht zu
mir einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken kampf
der kampf am computer da gibt es mehr zu
diesem wettkampf ansonsten würde ich mal
sagen bis dann bleibt dran